hi everyone my name is Tara chambers and
this is Tara's never seen an
outrageously sick last week's episode
was the fugitive which I absolutely
adored and in it
somebody said you'll now understand the
reference from the mess the one-armed
man reference and I disclosed that I
have never seen the mask so today I
watching the mask I'm pretty sure I've
actually always seen bits and pieces of
Ace Ventura pet detective
I can't remember I've seen if I've seen
the whole thing or if I've seen just
like pieces so I don't want to like do
an episode on it and then realize I have
actually seen the whole thing I really
don't want to have seen something and
then somebody to like comment like oh we
want that in high school Tamra you liar
and then like my credibility is shot
people already definitely give me those
mask predictions y'all have 20 minutes
use hashtag Tamra's never seen frog
emoji which is because it's green face
I'm very excited to this can't wait to
see it let's do it okay that was such a
blast that was so much fun I really want
to read the comic really bad it's got
such a like Who Framed Roger Rabbit vibe
just because he loves cartoons and
that's like the character he goes into
when he's wearing the mask it's just
right on the line as being way too
inappropriate for children but you could
still like pass it a little bit I would
love to see a full-on
adult version of this made that would be
so cool what are the first things I
wrote down is Oh Lord Cameron Diaz
literally looks like Jessica Rabbit
family who is Jim Carrey is set up as
like this nice guy and he's always
trying to get a girlfriend but he's so
nice overuse this character flaw the
first half-hour of this movie really
isn't about the mask at all it's really
setting up Stanley who is this like
friendly guy and he's got a friend who's
kind of a jerk but he's the like
your character that you get in like
every 90s film ever
who does it further the plot who is it
funny who does nothing like as a
character doesn't help anything he
annoyed the crap making the friends but
you see that the friend is like oh let's
go to this club and it's called the love
Safari Inn and then Tina is singing at
the club and it's just a whole thing
setting up the fact that Stanley's not
going to get into the club and so he's
denied access and he goes home defeated
and on his way home he sees somebody in
the river goes to save them
turns out it's just a mask with some
trash that's human shaped as always his
physical comedy is incredible I was
reading somewhere that they saved money
on like CGI I'm like special effects
because his face is so like elastic and
it's able to do so much stuff in his
body as well what a cool thing but they
loved the part right before she finds
the mask he kicks the car and the car
just falls apart and he just got such
great facials and such great body
movements and it just it always reads
hilariously to the point where if you're
not really matching him in the film it's
hard to find you likeable like the
detective the main comp character I did
not like him at all he first of all I
think a really bad actor he's super flat
he'll say a line and then the second
he's done saying line he'll completely
lose the character like he'll yell go
get him he immediately loses character I
feel like maybe he wouldn't be as bad if
he wasn't right next like playing right
against Jim Carrey who's like the king
of facials and the king of movement and
interesting to watch them together we're
done he gets home for work and doesn't
do his dog out for a walk and as a
previous dog walker that stresses me out
he's been gone all day buddy take your
dog out for a walk or good cast
so he's in his apartment and he turns
into the mask
and I just am on board from the
beginning I love that it plays into who
you are in the human turns you into just
a way a way more intense version of that
so he's very cartoony I said this before
but very Who Framed Roger Rabbit which
I've seen
just so everyone knows it's awesome
money goes to sleep he wakes up and it's
all real this is impossible
camera that 1d is impossible this injury
you then you find out about the whole
plot point of how Peggy the journalist
is here to ask him some questions and
Peggy super cute and nice as well and
they could probably end up together and
be super cute I never trusted Peggy not
from the start
never once did I trust Peggy he's got
his mind set on Cameron Diaz though so
he puts the math to go back on goes out
somebody stop me
it's the bet I am honestly digging
Cameron Diaz in this film and also is
that her voice singing in the club does
that really hurt I love love but when
actresses can sing I think that's the
coolest thing this is absolutely
stunning and I just I mean why didn't
they cast me in this role I know I was
three but they've seen this and known I
also wrote down there at the club
dancing and that's at that kids movies I
love the scene where he gets shot at he
yells out tell auntie em to let Old
Yeller out
it's like those memes words like Gandalf
and he's like find Harry Potter and
bring him to Narnia because our fight
against the Time Lord at the Death Star
you know when I raise all of those
together I love those memes and I love
it with the drop zone great job there
check like that like that then you get
the one-armed man reference which I get
I get that I started laughing out loud
when that happens it is so exciting to
get references you guys I looked this up
after the film because I was so
impressed with how they did the teeth
for the mask character I've tried to act
with like dentures in before and it is
it difficult to speak clearly I already
have a problem
speaking clearly I've got like that
California lay dead throw or I like it
sleep ugly that's and it's like not only
nothing is really clear and well you
know so it's already difficult for me to
do that so difficult with those teeth in
and it turns out that those were just
one of the first initial props like it
was just going to be for one visual cue
like to scare someone or something and
he Jim Carrey likes them so much he
learned how to speak with them so that
he could use them as often as possible
while in the math classroom I think
that's so cool good on you man that's
awesome so this is when all the police
all the cops are shooting at the mass
and he keeps changing from alpha into
alpha to outfit and I wrote down I've
always said if I could have one
superpower it would be teleportation but
dah dah dah
that might change to just outfit changes
if I could just have the mask powers and
said I might just do that
cuz damn and then I just wrote down god
damn it Peggy you crusty fill that in as
you will she sells them out from the
$50,000 so Stan Lee is arrested and put
in a police station and Milo comes in to
help get about because Milo is a great
friend and it's like well go get the
keys from the police officer and Milo
comes out with a piece of cheese in his
mouth and I wrote Milo with the cheese
is the true hero of this story bad guy
who now has the mask is like super
powerful he's gonna steal money because
that's all anyone ever wants get
creative people you can change outfits
really fast now come on everything's
resolved really quickly when Stanley
gets the mask back and then just eats
the balls and it explodes in his stomach
and everything's fine so the day is
saved possibly my favorite part is at
the end when the mayor tells the
detective to basically go jump off a
cliff because he's annoying and flat
nigga bad actor Stanley and Tina end up
together it was really fun but I knew it
would be great because Jim Carrey soul
so great at physical comedy y'all want
to see me watch some of the best at a
great time I just spit everywhere too
well well well beautiful you'll be
equally horrified and amused at the
whipping out of the condom yes however
the kiss spelled like Deadpool where
it's like no this isn't fortune I know
it's fun but adult can have fun too but
why is the Oscar statue made out of
glass yes why you will want to cosplay
and Cameron Diaz is dressed from her
dance number with Jim Carrey I would
love if I could pull that off not sure
my Jambo you may find a sudden urge to
purchase trendy pajamas complete with
pajama tie I mean this is pretty this is
pretty trendy there's boxes on my feet
so I'm pretty sure I'm rocking it right
now you'll find Stanley both pathetic
and charming also you'll really enjoy
the Cuban Pete sequence love the Cuban
Pete sequence I did find Stan Lee's
character to be written a little too
pathetic I think that whole like I hate
this term but like friend-zoned and the
whole like too nice of a guy
nice guys finish lat like I just I think
that's overdone a bit so that was a
little like okay we get it I get it I
get it little obnoxious but I mean the
whole movie is so over the top that it's
not I'm not complaining about that I'm
just saying that's kind of what I felt a
little bit so yeah for sure come on it's
Jim Carrey everyone loves him
except for Tommy Lee Jones he doesn't
care hahaha oh really good callback man
damn that was really good that is Clara
I'm going to stop that I love do the
predictions I really enjoy the
predictions a lot next week is going to
be probably escape from New York and
then the week after I don't know guys
getting ahead of ourselves
thank you so much for watching I will
see you next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you